what are my orders chief
i can do that stand by for vehicle drop
call shotgun
let's roll
[Music]
[Music]
right behind you sir
running shotgun let's move
on your seat spartan i got you
[Music]
let's go go go
[Music]
come on follow chief
we should investigate that tunnel at the
dick site chief
aren't you curious about what the
banished are digging for
[Music]
jump on out of that thing
[Music]
[Music]
open it up
keep your eyes peeled
wow
get me out of here
welcome to the conservatory
i wonder what the banished are looking
for down here
let's go find out
another spartan
get me close
[Music]
a drop wall module deployable cover
resilient but temporary
scan complete this is spartan vedrana
makovic armor's been offline for 13 days
cause of death is what an enhanced
energy blade same as spartan stone
there's a pattern emerging
chief who's doing this
we're going to find out
um
so
i'll kill you
so
so
your brothers
oh
hello
foreign
yes
[Applause]
hmm looks like the banished are trying
to stop us moving forward
can you open it
of course
if you can magic up a terminal of some
kind
or find an alternative power source to
get this door open
there we go simple
one good shotgun
yeah tricks
uh
what's that
okay
uh
hmm it needs more power find another one
uh
[Music]
shut him
up one big target
[Music]
and it's open come on
let's go before they get really creative
wait
do you hear that
it's coming from up ahead
open it
help me this installation the harbinger
exile was absolute how did she return
it's impossible this cannot be i need to
go back find out what happened we should
help her maybe
no she's correct i request your
assistance
who are you what's your name
i am despondent
monitor of this installation and this is
my conservatory my conservatory this is
not right
[Music]
let's go where down there
what were those flying things
new
dangerous
and despondent pyre
no
potentially dangerous
see you can be optimistic
[Applause]
we knew
[Music]
care not to die
so
ah
we're getting close to the bottom
wait listen
please do not do this it cannot happen
it is wrong
uh
[Music]
okay
yes
oh
for your life
[Music]
shall
[Music]
you can't hide from the baddest
now we make him
[Applause]
i will not relinquish to you
[Music]
i am ending it
[Music]
so
oh no we're too late
something awful happened here plug me in
we'll figure this out
you know what i want alas i do cortana
and my mind has not been changed this
installation's weapons may be yours but
its secrets are not
it's protected the containment facility
in particular
containment
the flood why would a
you and i both know that there are worse
things than the flood within this ring
no
there's no way you could know
so you've come for me at last
why are you doing this john
why don't you understand
the seal must not be broken the punished
cannot be freed this can never be
negotiated there is no other choice
reconsider the consequences of your
request back to your conservatory
monitor
what does that mean what could be worse
than the flood
nothing good
find us a way out
on it
remember when you said new and dangerous
uh-huh
you were right
[Applause]
hostile reinforcements
inbound this is taking longer than i
thought
something is taking control of local
systems
where are all these skimmers coming from
is that what we're calling them
well i was also considering flying
octopus monkeys skimmers it is then
wow
uh
ties up reinforcements
the door
i know the code is being rewritten
altered using a forerunner routine
my
more of them chief
show them
[Music]
i'm done come get me
what happened back there
when i interfaced with the cradle it
unlocked something something important
cortana was here six months ago i could
feel what she felt when you arrived it
was joy
fear and pain
chief is that another
[Music]
a thruster module evasive maneuvers on
demand
now then
who are you
scan complete
spartan theodore sorel special weapons
expert died 13 days ago like makovich
the assassin brutes
more than one
whoever they are they're proficient well
trained
we've got a score to settle
[Music]
sneaking somewhere
chief that platform we're too late
not yet
i crave a real
chief that platform we're too late
not yet
oh
they were
persistent
did they kill spartan sorrell
negative his killers are still active
[Music]
this elevator it's taking us back to the
surface
it doesn't make sense
why come all the way down here just to
kill the monitor
the monitor's purpose is to protect the
ring
so why kill her
no idea
show yourself
i know you have been following me
we are not enemies
the spawned empire
she has something i required
i know of you reclaimer
but hear this
you are not the future you okay chief
i'm trying to get the armor unlocked try
harder
the forerunner's lies are at an end i am
the harbinger of the truth
the endless will be found
they will ascend now would be good i
know i know
three the reformation begins two
one go
[Music]
i took too long
you could have been killed
it's okay
you saved us both